on en voit ce qu'est ce que ces variants
le delta c'est une modification nouvelle
combinaison nouvelle conformation ces
gens sont tous jeunes vraiment jeune
jamais vu ça c'est incroyable ce variant
est le résultat du grand nombre de
malades
le virus peut infecter d'autres cellules
sans s'exposer aux anticorps existants
c'est à dire qu'il ya 1500 milliards de
mutation par jour et n'êtes pas matinée
non j'étais assez stupide pour quoi eh
bien j'ai été diot bon je comprends
qu'il s'agit d'avariés indien les
poumons sont complètement atteint
organise ce scan et vous voyez une tache
blanche avec de petites son club du
tissu sain qu'un merveilleux animal de
ce type étaient créées en laboratoire
accidentellement accidentellement oui
parmi vous qui s'est fait vacciner lever
la main c'est à dire que tu penses
vraiment que les chinois ont apporté des
changements à ce virus
malgré le fait qu'ils s'adaptent sa
gravité ne diminue pas ça n'arrivait pas
avant
[Musique]
donc tout est plan en ce moment non pas
en ce moment il y à des lits libres
les gens continuent à sortir de
l'hôpital malgré tout pour 14 15% par
jour au début il n'y avait rien c'est
évident
non ici c'était comme c'est maintenant
s'était construit construit oui oui mais
ce n'était pas plein non ce n'était pas
plein je ne peux pas parler maintenant
prenez le s'il vous plaît suivez le
alors je vais vous présenter nos
infrastructures
il y à l'hôpital peu de mots logique de
roubles nouveau 300 lits à peu près un
centre périnatal 500 lits à peu près il
y à 1347 lis ici puis 150 lits de
rétablissement donc 1200 ce n'est pas
l'hôpital d'infectiologie qui
travaillent en cinq mois nous avons
réussi malgré les circonstances a livré
des soins médicaux de haute qualité dans
leur intégralité
on dirait un parfum français non comme
un parfum oui ça vous plaît ça ne sent
pas l'alcool non non ça sent bon et
comment ça se fait c'est comme ça et
c'est sûr que ça protège sûr et certain
ça a été vérifiée le nouveau variant bon
qu'est ce que c'est marion le delta qui
sait ils sont tous pareils en réalité il
s'agit de multiples mutations du
variantes de furannes dans lesquels en
plus d'un certain nombre de mutations
peu significative elles sont toutes
multiples il y a environ 20 mutation de
l'original
le génome entier est composé de trente
mille lettres et 20 sont remplacés tout
les substitution ne sont pas forcément
significative dans le sens où elle ne
donne pas forcément un avantage au virus
mais ce n'est pas juste ça il y à un
petit nombre de variations importantes
c'est dans la couronne que ça se produit
on appelle ça la rb des sur les pics de
la protéine s les plus éloignés de la
particule virale elle même se trouve une
structure qui comme une clé avec un
verrou interagit avec les récepteurs de
nos cellules
c'est cette interaction qui permet au
virus de reconnaître et d'infecter nos
cellules cette partie du virus a été
modifié dans ce variant plusieurs
résidus d'acides aminés ont été
remplacés cela conduit au fait qu'une
telle clé modifié interagit mieux avec
la serrure et plus rapidement il s'agit
d'une réaction purement chimique a + b
forme un composé ab dans une mutation du
virus ça va plus vite
par conséquent toutes choses égales par
ailleurs s'il ya une cellule humaine et
deux virus
l'un étant celui de départ celui de
kuran et l'autre la mutation en question
ce dernier interagira probablement plus
rapidement
d'une part il est plus infectieux ce qui
signifie que le nombre de personnes que
le porteur peut infecter augmente en
termes d'épidémiologie de mesures
gouvernementales ce petit changement
peut devenir un cauchemar
regardez voilà des lits libre là-bas
libre il ya un petit bout de libre
là c'est libre il y à cette partie là en
partie et puis là ici il ya 1400 1347
lee 1347 lee 1347 lit et combien y at-il
de compartiments nous ne couvrons pas en
compartiments là là je vois des blocs en
secteur 1 2 3 4
d'accord 4 secteur milly à 19,20 une
seconde ceux ci sont fermées ce sont des
unités de soins intensifs en fait rien
ce sont des compartiments quand même oui
oui c'est libre là-bas ce sont des lits
d'observation de soins intensifs
quatre lits par compartiment c ça et si
on compte par compartiment oui quatre
lits bonjour je ne pensais même pas que
je reviendrai un jour ici j'espérais ne
plus jamais revenir
jamais et c'est touchant un hôpital
qu'ovide les gens suffoque
et voilà qu'il est écrit nous vous
souhaitons une bonne humeur eh bien on
n'allait quand même pas souhaité une
mauvaise humeur quand est ce qu'il est
devenu évident que beaucoup de gens
commençaient à arriver
il y environ un mois et demi c'est à
dire fin mai début juin à peu près oui
beaucoup de monde à la fois pas tout de
suite non c'était presque comme une
formation pour nous nous avons admis un
nombre de patients assez important et
quand il a augmenté nous étions prêts je
parle non pas de 30 40 mais disons de 50
60 patients
encore une fois l'hôpital et encore une
fois ces équipements on s'habillait en
vitesse qui aura le plus vite
skoda ou moi je pense que ce sera moi
ce variant est le résultat du grand
nombre de malades parce que pendant la
maladie
des milliers de nouveaux variants se
forme chez chaque personne
le virus est en mutation constante mais
la grande majorité des variants meurent
car les mutations sont généralement
mauvaises pour le virus mais si il y à
un milliard et demi de personnes comme
en inde avec des milliers de mutants par
jour la quantité est telle qu un mutant
bénéfique pour le virus doit finir par
apparaître
c'est à dire qu'il ya 1500 milliards de
mutation par jour j'ai même peur de
comptes et ça ne rentre pas dans ma tête
par conséquent il y à une sélection de
certaines des séquences des gènes les
plus bénéfiques pour l'existence du
virus
quelle en est l'astuce principal
on sait depuis le début que puisque
l'infection et zoonotique elle ne
correspond pas complètement aux
récepteurs humains
par conséquent les variations du génome
qui se fixent le plus facilement à notre
récepteur la co2 sont les plus
prometteuses
d'abord c'était le variant britanniques
puis le sud africain il s'attache de
mieux en mieux à ce récepteur lorsqu'il
sa tâche il injecte leurs acides
nucléiques dans la cellule
en conséquence la souche indienne a
produit trois mutations à la fois
nouvelle combinaison nouvelle
conformation il s'est développé d'une
nouvelle manière
après tout la substances protéiques
n'est pas rigide comme un bâton à les
flexibles comme un fil de pêche
ce fils a donc commencé à mieux coller à
nos cellules
voilà tout pourquoi cela s'est produit
en inde selon toa à cause du grand
nombre d'habitants oui à cause du grand
nombre de malades à cause d'un système
de santé public complètement au point
mort à cause du fait que rien n'a été
fait non pas parce qu'il ne voulait pas
mais parce qu'il ne pouvait plus rien
faire
il ne pouvait pas observé les distances
il n'y avait pas de masquer les morts
étaient tout simplement enterrer dehors
le virus s'est transmis de manière très
intense rien ne pouvait l'empêcher
avec quoi avez vous été vaccinées
spoutnik moi aussi avec spoutnik
avec quoi d'autre sinon bah oui avec
quoi d'autre écoutez il y a aussi des
espaces vides ici oui c'est libre
les réserves des compartiments pour deux
personnes oui attention ici comment
l'hôpital at il commencé à se remplir
il a commencé à se remplir
progressivement la situation s'est
développée de telle manière qu à
l'ouverture des cliniques les patients
qui se trouvaient dans les cliniques
sont venus progressivement vers nous et
l'hôpital a commencé à se remplir
il y avait 10 15 20 30 40 patients
mais quand on met juin nous avons
remarqué une augmentation ça a été
soudain ça n'a pas été soudain disons
que ça suivait une trajectoire comme le
processus d'infection
parce qu'à part nous il ya d'autres
grands hôpitaux qui ont admis des
patients comme une harka nous puis
l'hôpital numéro 15 du jour sobianine
hirakova ont annoncé qu une grave
épidémie avait réellement commencé
lorsque la ville a annoncé qu on passé
de 3000 à 9000 personnes d'un coup nous
l'avons ressenti nous mêmes comment ça
s'est passé
alors écoutez on admettait 50 patients
par jour et là soudain sans puis 110 120
130 et donc petit à petit ça a contribué
à ce que le personnel soit formé
le pire dans ce métier c'est quand le
personnel n'est pas prêt et nous avons
une équipe qui a fait ses preuves
on dit que le virus mute
vous dites qu'il mute comment s'est-il
vert ou mutés cet homme en fait à poser
une question tout à fait raisonnable
car quand on parle de tout ça on
présente ça comme une guerre il y a un
petit hitler le virus on est en guerre
avec lui et il passe à l'action
le virus ne mute dans aucune direction
le virus mute par accident sans doute
est il même faux de dire qu'il mute tout
simplement quand le virus se multiplie
dans nos cellules
son information génétique est copiée
mais avec des erreurs plus de gens sont
infectés plus de variantes du virus
apparaissent je ne veux même pas dire
que le virus est en train de muter
certains de ces variants s'avère plus
adaptable de sorte que plus il ya de cas
d'infection dans un pays plus il est
probable qu'un variant convenable pour
le virus apparaissent et soit mieux
adapté que d'autres variant à un même
endroit
peu à peu ce nouveau variant commencera
à gagner du terrain par conséquent le
variant indien est très probablement
apparue précisément dans le contexte
d'un très grand nombre d'infectés c'est
quoi la différence entre ce virus est le
premier il ya une différence
oui d'abord il est plus contagieux nous
contagieux donc plus contagieux la
deuxième différence est que la maladie
progresse plus rapidement si avant
l'aspect clinique changé en l'espace de
sept à huit jours maintenant les données
de tomographie et de radio les
indicateurs cliniques peuvent changer en
l'espace de deux jours très rapidement
j'ai une amie qui était à 15% et deux
jours plus tard elle était déjà 90
absolument
c'est la principale différence voilà les
lits de réserve et là aussi ils
n'étaient pas visibles depuis là-bas il
est très important que les gens évitent
l'automédication
s'il ya un problème il faut en parler et
contacter immédiatement le personnel
médical
l'état du patient doit être surveillé
tout le monde pousse tout le monde à une
pneumonie
tous souffrent de problèmes pulmonaires
et bien notre collègue je dis ça notre
cameraman il s'est littéralement échappé
de la quarantaine pour être soigné chez
lui à briand sq est maintenant ses
poumons sont atteints à 100%
la question est pourquoi pourquoi et qui
avait besoin de ce pseudo héroïsme il a
33 ans il est crucial de comprendre que
le variant delta n'est pas un virus
complètement nouveau
c'est une modification qui provoque une
pathogénèse un peu plus grave qui est un
peu plus capable d'échapper à la réponse
immunitaire qui est un peu plus
contagieux mais ce n'est pas un virus
fondamentalement nouveau par conséquent
tout ce que nous scentifique avons
développé dans le cadre de notre travail
au niveau du coronavirus tout cela reste
valable et fonctionne c'est à dire que
les glucocorticoïdes nous protège
toujours les anticoagulants fonctionne
toujours
les médicaments antiviraux même s'ils ne
sont pas très efficaces fonctionne plus
ou moins les vaccins aussi notre
immunité n'est pas une ampoule
elle ne peut pas être simplement éteinte
notre niveau d'anticorps a simplement
augmenter et la quantité de virus que
nous pouvons repousser avec les
anticorps a diminué cependant l'immunité
créé avec les vaccins fonctionne
toujours
il y a beaucoup de jeunes ça touche
beaucoup plus les jeunes maintenant ici
à l'hôpital je me souviens très bien de
la première et de la deuxième vague
il s'agissait pour la plupart de
personnes âgées
il y avait des panneaux et partout
c'était écrit
1952 1947 1938 vous souvenez c'était
comme ça oui
maintenant regardez tous ces gens sont
plus jeunes que moi regardez d'abord les
personnes âgées se sont mises à la
vaccination
beaucoup sont vaccinés ensuite il faut
compter que beaucoup ont été malades est
le plus important
la discipline distance masques gants
ainsi que se tenir en retrait des
événements publics cela brisera
également la chaîne des infections
les jeunes pensent que ça ne va pas leur
arriver
malheureusement la réalité est tout
autre
les jeunes tombent également malades et
la maladie évolue sous une forme grave
et malheureusement aussi avec des
conséquences défavorables
vous pensez que ça dépend de quoi de la
charge virale une personne va dans une
foule quelqu'un éternue à côté et bien
tout d'abord il appelle trop tard le
médecin
il n'y croit pas il pense que le virus
est parti mais en fait il n'est partie
nulle part il mène une vie active
il pense que ça va passer on peut
appeler un médecin demain deux jours
passent il pense que c'est comme une
infection respiratoire
sept jours de maladie et ça passe rien
de tel chaque jour aggrave la maladie
si généralement le virus s'épuise ce
n'est pas le cas ici
il prend plutôt de la force et aggravent
l'état du patient je ne pouvais même pas
imaginer qu'ils étendent jeunes
pourquoi cela arrive-t-il événement de
masse soirée et voilà le résultat
ces gars là ont vingt trente ans et j'ai
vu que l'épidémie concerner beaucoup
plus les jeunes désormais un concerne
deux fois plus les jeunes à la rajeunit
de manière dramatique
comment tu expliques l'inde c'est comme
ça bon je comprends qu'il s'agit d'un
variant bien quelle est la particularité
de ce récepteur à ce2 sa quantité
s'accumulent à la surface des cellules
chez les personnes âgées
il est grandement les cellules à capter
l'oxygène une personne vieilli à la de
plus en plus besoin de lui
c'est pourquoi ils sont morts maintenant
il s'est adapté à que c'est bon je n'ai
plus besoin de tant de récepteurs je
m'en sortirai de toute façon se dit il
c'est précisément ça c'est ce virus-là
qui prendra la relève
quel est le problème la maladie
devraient évoluer plus facilement mais
ce n'est pas le cas mais ce n'est pas le
cas et là c'est ce qui m'inquiète que
doit faire une personne qui commence à
ressentir les symptômes de ce qu vide
la première chose à faire est de
consulter un médecin
ne pensez pas que cela va pas c'est que
vous pouvez y faire face
non impossible
il ne faut pas compter sur le hasard
vous avez besoin de voir un médecin
d'accord d'accord et si le médecin dit
tout va bien pour vous votre température
et de 38,9 la lésion pulmonaire et de
25%
on ne vous a nommé pas l'hôpital c'est
possible et en même temps on dit que la
lésion pulmonaire pourrait passer au
niveau supérieur le lendemain chaque
personne a sa propre réponse immunitaire
le professionnalisme d'un médecin réside
précisément dans l'évaluation correcte
de l'état du patient et si le médecin
ambulanciers qui vient ne fait pas le
test pcr mais il peut demander depuis
combien de temps la personne est malade
telle est sa température s'il ya des
symptômes cliniques évaluer la
saturation
il ya déjà quatre facteurs qui
permettent de décider s'il faut
hospitaliser le patient ou non si sa
saturation en oxygène est inférieure à
90 et qu'il est malade depuis quatre à
cinq jours il sera hospitalisé en
collaboration avec l'université d'état
de moscou
nous avons traité une grande quantité de
données en établissant un diagnostic des
lésions du tissu pulmonaire
cette calculatrice peut être utilisé
n'importe tout le département des
technologies de l'information de la
ville de moscou et le département de la
santé du gouvernement nous ont beaucoup
aidés il existe 3 calculatrice de ce
genre dans le monde
l'une est la nôtre puis les chinois ont
travaillé ils ont environ 2500 à 3000
entrées john hopkins est environ 5000 et
nous avons cinq cent mille entrées
traités et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
cette calculatrice
elle permet de déterminer le degré de
lésion pulmonaire et aussi de choisir
les médicaments si le patient est dans
le système électronique de suivi médical
et mias alors la machine à l'aide de
certaines données détermine les signaux
que l'on retrouve le plus souvent
laboratoire la machine trade cela et
permet de détecter les lésions du tissu
pulmonaire
quand faut-il vraiment commencer à
s'inquiéter passer aux soins intensifs
quand la protéine c réactive et
supérieur avant nous nous concentrons
toujours sur les paramètres du
métabolisme respiratoires il est clair
qu'avant le coc vide il était difficile
d'imaginer
et que nous aurions besoin a procédé à
des apports en oxygène dans un service
ordinaire depuis le début du grand vide
le recours à cette méthode d'assistance
respiratoire
l'apport en oxygène a permis de retenir
les admissions déraisonnable en unité de
soins intensifs et il beaucoup de gens
sous oxygène en ce moment il ya 56
patients sur 70 sous ventilation 4
patients sur 54 ans aux inhalations
invasive d'accord et en quoi le débit
est il différent avec l'inhalation
d'oxygène à haut débit des canules
nasale sont utilisées elles sont
solidement attaché c'est à dire que
quand c'est à haut débit c'est à l'aide
de canule et kan c non invasif on
utilise un masque
le deuxième problème lié à tous ces
variants delta réside dans le simple
fait que si le virus interagit avec la
cellule comme ça et bien afin d'empêcher
cette interaction vous mettez une sorte
de bouchon pour que le virus ne puisse
pas interagir avec la cellule et donc
pour ce qui est des anticorps
neutralisants qui se produisent dans
notre corps notamment à l'aide des
vaccins les plus efficaces d'entre eux
se fixe justement à cet endroit de la
particule de coronavirus ainsi ils
bloquent sa capacité à interagir avec
nos cellules et nous sauve de
l'infection ou du moins rang l'affection
moins probable mais le problème est que
ces anticorps sont produits pour la
protéine s du variant originale de
houran et puisque les nouveaux variants
ont changé précisément cette partie avec
laquelle ces anticorps devrait se lier
les anticorps se lit également comme une
clé avec un verrou il s'avère que le
virus obtient un double avantage
d'une part il interagit plus rapidement
avec nos cellules et par conséquent
produit plus de progéniture virale par
unité de temps et d'autre part il est
moins efficacement inhibé réprimée par
les anticorps développé chez les
individus qui ont été infectés par le
variant originale de au crâne et qui ont
été vaccinées à l'aide des composants de
ce variant on suppose donc que ce virus
peut nécessiter un nouveau vaccin
non on ne suppose pas
parce que l'interaction moins efficace
avec la particule virale des anticorps
développé à partir du vaccin originale
de première génération ne signifie pas
que l'inhibition ne se produira pas nous
tous en tant que consommateur sommes en
fin de compte simplement intéressé par
l'idée d'empêcher l'infection de se
propager
de sorte que notre système immunitaire
avec ou sans l'aide de béquilles sous la
forme par exemple d'un vaccin puisse
vaincre la propagation de l'infection
les changements qui se produisent dans
les nouveaux variants en particulier
dans le variant delta réduisent
l'efficacité de reconnaissance de la
particule virale par les anticorps de
combien de trois peut être quatre fois
mais dans tous les cas ce changement ne
signifie pas que nous n'avons aucune
protection
il y à une protection dans tous les cas
comment y at il parmi ces milliers de
personnes qui sont ici de gens vaccinés
et bien environ 10 15 mais ça peut aller
jusqu'à 20 personnes
oui personne ce n'est pas en pourcentage
non c'est à dire pour 1000 personnes
il y a quinze vacciner 10 à 15 et ces
gens quelles formes de la maladie
c'est un degré d'attendre pulmonaire un
ou deux c'est à dire une légère lésion
pulmonaire
oui pas de lésions graves non en tout
cas il n'y en a pas dans l'unité de
soins intensifs
d'accord autrement dit il n'y a pas de
personnes vaccinées en soins intensifs
non c'est l'unité de soins intensifs
c'est ça voilà soins intensifs ces gens
sont tous jeunes oui vraiment jeune tout
jeune jamais vu ça c'est incroyable je
veux dire tout le monde ici est plus
jeune que moi
en plus des soins intensifs nous avons
mis en place des lits de surveillance
intensive et quand les patients arrivent
si on voit que la personne n'a par
exemple une forte fièvre
on ne place pas ce patient immédiatement
en soins intensifs mais il est surveillé
comme s'ils étaient en soins intensifs
et ce ne sont pas les médecins ordinaire
qui le surveille mais les urgentistes
prenons les vaccins par exemple et les
vaccins vectorielles et probablement
même les vaccins à m
ils sont moins efficaces contre le
nouveau variant que contre celui des
orane ils sont fabriqués sur la base de
la souche de au crâne c'est ça eh bien
oui c'est ça mais nous savons encore une
fois l'immunité n'est pas une ampoule
électrique
alors oui il y à une baisse et même chez
nous il y à une baisse selon diverses
données certains disent que c'est une
baisse de 5 à 6 x 8 x même certains
disent que c'est deux fois et demie il
me semble que si cela diminue de 8 fois
c'est bien pire que deux fois et demie
cela semble correct n'est ce pas mais en
fait les immunités et ses titres sont
mesuré sur une échelle différente
dix fois cent fois plus de mille fois
c'est comme ça que la dilution des
sérums et effectué par conséquent la
baisse n'est pas assez forte pour dire
que les vaccins ne sont plus efficaces
oui nous pouvons dire maintenant que les
vaccins ne protège pas complètement
contre l'infection
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le taux
d'efficacité a chuté c'est ce que nous
avons calculé pour la population
britannique pour la population russe
nous n'avons pas encore pu le faire mais
nous pouvons extrapolé que l'efficacité
de pfizer et de modern a a diminué de 10
% environ pour astrazeneca aussi il y à
une baisse de 10 à 15% par rapport au
niveau auquel il se trouvait à l'origine
donc pour le spoutnik chevet ça sera à
peu près la même chose
le degré de protection diminuera de 10 à
15% au niveau de la population
mais ces chiffres ne sont pas si mauvais
nous restons toujours bien au-dessus de
50 % initialement proposé par l' oms et
la fédé a pour choisir un ce
d'efficacité des vaccins
donc je crois que le jeu n'est pas du
tout perdu comment vous vous sentez je
suis en pleine forme depuis combien de
temps vous êtes ici je me trouve ici
depuis déjà quinze jours prend vous
amener ici vous aviez une forte fièvre
oui j'avais de la fièvre j'ai appelé une
ambulance et j'ai été amenée ici
et puis mon état s'est aggravé
brusquement lorsque moi ça veut dire
quoi
en deux jours peut-être le décalage 47
47 comme moi est ce que c'est la barre
c'est de l'oxygène
c'est de l'oxygène c'est ça vous avez
une canule ou quoi non non ça va je peux
faire une pause quel degré d'atteinte
pulmonaire avait voulu j'étais à 75 % si
je me trompe pas 75%
c'est le degré d'atteinte 3 je crois que
j'ai été transféré ici depuis les soins
intensifs hier vous étiez en soins
intensifs
oui vous receviez de l'oxygène à haut
débit c'est ça et quel était ce débit 80
n'ont généralement ces 30 40 litres
environ 30 40 litres par minute mais ce
n'est pas le plus haut débit il ya aussi
80 litres des patients dont les poumons
sont atteints et 90 % ou plus reçoivent
80 litres mais je me sentais vraiment
très mal
vous avez eu un choc cytokines hic oui
d'accord c'est à dire que vous aviez 40
de fièvre
oui 40 et plus vous n'êtes pas vacciné
non j'ai été assez stupide pour quoi et
bien j'étais diop et ips on pourra me
paie sans savoir le bipe rats mais
comment ça on a toutes les possibilités
aujourd'hui écoutés en fait j'ai
beaucoup voyagé il s'est avéré que
j'avais trois vols internationaux le
mois où je devais recevoir le vaccin
voilà quelqu'un qui pense que je voyage
au lieu de me faire vacciner
il est presque mort avec 40 de fièvre
j'ai failli mourir oui mais l'histoire
de l'infection en elle-même est
intéressante elle et vous savez plutôt
comique
alors vous savez comment c'est arrivé
oui écoutez je suis allée de denver à
las vegas de las vegas je suis allé à
los angeles
j'ai participé au forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg voilà le forum
économique
oui le maudit forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg non là je ne suis pas
d'accord il y avait un très bon système
de contrôle et quand nous y sommes
arrivés
tout fonctionnait bien mais quand je
suis rentré à la maison et que j'ai
embrassé ma belle mère elle était déjà
malade à ce moment là c'est votre
belle-mère qui vous infecter
oui c'est la belle-mère qui est coupable
sacrée belle mère j'attendais ce moment
il ne blâmerai pas denver ni les vols ni
le forum
mais sa belle mère qui l'a affecté bonne
chance à vous à vous aussi
les poumons sont complètement atteint
organes et ce scan et vous voyez une
tache blanche avec deux petites enclaves
de tissus sains c'est fantastique je ne
vois pas du tout de personnes âgées
l'île de personnes qui seraient vraiment
surpoids
tous ces hommes n'ont évidemment pas de
diabète oui ce sont surtout ceux qui
voyagent oui voilà je suis allée de
denver à los angeles puis à las vegas
puis je suis allé au forum économique
et puis l'embrasser quelqu'un et puis ma
belle-mère va infecter la sape la
vaccination est-elle nécessaire et à
quel point c'est efficace
quel contenu de la vaccination combien
de temps ça peut durer la vaccination
est nécessaire il ya aujourd'hui des
données sur ce sujet tout le monde d'y
aller vacciner reste toujours porteurs
du virus et donc on ne les laissera pas
utiliser le taxi mais en réalité les
personnes vaccinées
précisément parce que leur système
immunitaire est plus ou moins prêtes à
combattre l'infection dès le début
produisent moins de virus et par
conséquent infecte moins deux personnes
voilà et le but est vraiment de rompre
ces chaînes vous devriez considérer cela
comme un processus exponentielle par
exemple vous m'avez infecté mois est
aussi quelqu'un d'autre puis chacun
d'entre nous va affecter deux autres
personnes etc
le processus commence à se développer
comme ça si vous n'avez infectés que moi
et que vous n'avez pas infectés une
autre personne parce que vous produisez
moins de virus soit parce que vous êtes
vacciné soit parce que vous portez un
masque peu importe les méthodes que vous
utilisez cette propagation ne sera plus
exponentielle mais linéaire
si vous avez infecté moins d'une
personne pendant toute la durée de votre
maladie
le processus va s'étouffer naturellement
aujourd'hui nous avons vacciné à peu
près 10% de la population dans le pays
la vaccination obligatoire était
nécessaire ou pas et bien si vous voulez
savoir mon opinion personnelle je pense
que oui avant tout c'est pour assurer la
sécurité des gens de notre société
c'est très important
bien sûr il ne faut pas arrêter les gens
dans les rues
et moi je les arrêts très bien à ici on
a les filles pardon dit qu'ici c'est la
salle des femmes les femmes sont plus
âgés que les hommes les hommes sont tous
jeunes et les femmes sont plus âgés
allons faire un tour les femmes sont
plus responsables les femmes évitent les
foules mais il ya maintenant beaucoup
plus de femmes viennent ici bien sûr
mais tout de même les familles s'y sont
plus âgés que les hommes mais ça ce
n'est que de la thérapie tout ça oui
les patients ici ont la forme légère de
la maladie eh bien vous savez ceux qui
arrivent ici il n'y a pas de formes
légères je ne dirais pas qu'ils ont une
forme légère c'est vrai oui et après les
gens se rétablisse pendant six mois
s'ils ont de la chance il y a trois
principaux groupes de vaccins les
premiers vaccins sont les vaccins basés
sur adénovirus ceux ci comprennent
d'astrazeneca spoutnik vais bien sûr
johnson and johnson et quelques autres
sinovac peut-être oui oui ou sinopharm
les vaccins chinois
oui c'est à dire que ce groupe avec
teurs adénovirus a ses particularités
le deuxième groupe est constitué de
vaccins à arn on en connaît de kaiser et
moderna on en produit beaucoup
aujourd'hui je sais que les coréens
n'ont écrit aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient
presque terminé et commencerait à tester
un vaccin à arn et le troisième groupe
ce sont les vaccins inactivés c'est ce
que fabriquent le centre tube accord oui
notre centre tchoumakov il y en a
beaucoup d'autres y compris le vaccin
kazakh beaucoup de vaccins inactivés son
produit là où il y avait des centres de
production qui permettait de créer
d'accumuler des volumes nécessaires de
virus là ils sont pour ainsi dire traité
tués et puis on en fait des vaccins il
ya déjà un certain nombre de vaccins
combinés qui sont l'avenir que sont les
vaccins combinés
par exemple un vaccin qui ne contient
pas d'adn au virus ne contient pas
d'arène mais contient simplement la
protéine s
qui a été produit dix ans par des packs
hulot vie rida et il est nettoyé de
manière spéciale puis injectée mais
jusqu'à présent ils sont si peu nombreux
et comme c'est une technologie de
vaccination du siècle dernier
bien sûr ils seront en retard mais ils
sont peu coûteux fiable il ne se soucie
pas trop de questions car la technologie
est ancienne et avec le temps ils seront
partout mais cela prendra du temps
voilà la situation pour aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on peut dire en se basant
sur des documents officiels de toutes
sortes et je les suis tous ceux de l'
oms des cdc des documents russe le début
de la revaccination avec le spoutnik v a
été annoncé qu'est ce que ça signifie
ceux qui surveillent constate que le
vaccin est chou de plus en plus souvent
on reçoit plus de malades mais oui vous
avez raison
cela ne conduit pas à la mort comme
c'était le cas avant que les gens
commencent à recevoir le vaccin
oui cela conduit à ce que ma soeur à une
forme légère aussi son mari également
quatre ou cinq mois après s'être fait
vacciner avec le spoutnik
autrement dit le ministère de la santé a
décidé qu'il était temps de faire une
revaccination ils ont raison
j'ai été en soin intensif pendant
presque un mois j'ai une forme grave de
la maladie
peut-être que les conséquences auraient
été moins lourde si un vaccin va avait
été administré je voulais me faire
vacciner mais je ne les ai pas fait à
temps et voici le résultat désastreux
je suis dans un état grave j'ai locaux
vides
pourquoi selon vous les gens ne se font
pas vacciner
eh bien ça a commencé dans les années
1990 souvenez vous de cette campagne
contre la vaccination et de toutes ces
folies
nous ne vaccinerons pas contre la
rougeole nous ne vaccinerons pas contre
la varicelle
nous n'administrons aucun vaccin
quelqu'un leur a mis cette idée en tête
que la vaccination était quelque chose
de mauvais mais cela protège des
épidémies si vous prenez la période
soviétique
personne ne demande à personne vaccinée
ou pas tout le monde a été vaccinée et
c'est ce qui sauve est toute la
population
absolument toute la population chaque
pandémie se termine
par la vaccination il faut briser la
chaîne de contamination
vous vous souvenez quand il avait le
confinement il fallait briser cette
chaîne
maintenant c'est la vaccination c'est
pour détruire la chaîne de contamination
c'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est le plus
important après cela se forment une
couche des gens immunisés tout le monde
est soulagé et les gens retournent à la
vie normale et ce virus devient
saisonniers tout cela est objectif oui
les jeunes tombent malades aussi les
jeunes meurent aussi
et votre certitude que vous serez
épargné et venez donc ce soir prenez un
revolver si vous avez un permis de port
d'armes
mettez y des balles et jouer à la
roulette russe eh bien c'est la même
attitude face à ce qui se passe ne pas
se faire vacciner ou jouer à la roulette
russe
une balle est entrée dans votre tête et
bien pas de chance grosso modo si vous
avez envie de jouer avec la réalité
comme si vous jouiez à la roulette russe
je ne pense pas que ce soit raisonnable
tu es le premier à qui je confie cette
idée je veux vraiment que d'autres
scientifiques comme on dit ils pensent
aussi tu vois dans ce cas il semble que
l'évolution du virus était été modifié
si le virus apparaît naturellement même
l'interaction entre les souris et les
humains les humains et les souris et
vice et versa s'effectue selon ses
propres lois
ce n'est pas possible que hélas nous
avons ce qui est évident un insert
artificielle qui divise cette protéine
est ce en deux parties il est artificiel
il n'y a pas de tel insère dans les
autres coronavirus cela correspond à ce
que de nombreux scientifiques disent
voyez vous c'est un cerf artificiel il a
été probablement ajoutés aux
laboratoires
c'est à dire que tu penses vraiment que
les chinois ont apporté des changements
à ce virus
oui je le crois il n'a pas pu se
transformer lui même de cette manière et
avoir une telle ampleur qu'il se
transforme comme ça lui même provoque
une telle pandémie
nous avons déjà eu des coronavirus à
deux reprises et rien de grave ne s'est
passé avec le premier sarce 800
personnes sont mortes et maintenant tu
comprends ces quatre millions de morts
le maire située à 35 %
il devait en être ainsi ce virus était
étranger les gens tombaient malades
gravement malade il mourrait mais la
transmission de ce virus est compliquée
et dans ce virus du fait qu'il hommes on
peut supposer d'une manière ou d'une
autre
sa structure s'est transformée en celle
qui vise les humains pas les souris
c'est là que cette transition a eu lieu
je comprends que c'est une pure
spéculation
je ne cherche à convaincre personne il
ya des spécialistes pour ça c'est à eux
de s'en occuper mais ce qui m'inquiète
terriblement c'est que malgré le fait
qu'ils s'adaptent sa gravité ne diminue
pas ça n'arrivait pas avant
vous pensez que ce virus est
artificielle je ne pense pas il ya une
hypothèse selon laquelle le virus est
apparu à la suite des actions d'un
certain docteur denfer qui étaient
chinois ce docteur denfer et il aurait
fait bouillir quelque chose dans son
flacon vert et il l'a fait
intentionnellement afin de nous faire du
mal à tous je n'y crois pas du tout car
un virus c'est d'une part et on nous
apprend ça à tous un objet biologique
des plus simples mais en réalité son
effet est très complexe car lui même est
en quelque sorte un objet inanimé il
interagit avec nos cellules qu'il
infecte puis avec tout l'organisme
et ainsi de suite en général pour
construire un bon virus par exemple un
virus de combat vous devez très bien
comprendre comment fonctionne tout
l'organisme
et nous ne le comprenons tout simplement
pas il est donc impossible de construire
un virus selon un schéma
personne ne peut le faire pour créer une
certaine forme en laboratoire qui serait
légèrement modifié par rapport à la
forme naturelle par exemple pour
qu'elles acquièrent la capacité
d'infecter des cellules humaines pas des
personnes mais des cellules humaines
parce que des expériences dans un
laboratoire se font en culture de telles
expériences peuvent être faites
de telles expériences ont été faites et
à la suite d'une telle sélection en
laboratoire quelque chose aurait pu être
créés mais il est impossible de savoir
quel sera le résultat final
vous devez donc alors supposer qu'il ya
eu tout simplement une fuite
accidentelle mais non intentionnelle et
surtout pas mal intentionnés mais qu'un
merveilleux animal de ce type a été créé
en laboratoire
accidentellement accidentellement oui
latynina écrit que quelqu'un a pris un
tour de vis et a commencé à bricoler
quelque chose bon ce n'est pas possible
c'est possible dans le sens où il ya eu
des précédents de ce genre par exemple
en union soviétique
lors du développement d'armes
bactériologiques il y à une fuite d'une
souche de la fièvre charbonneuse de
combat à la fin des années 70 as vers le
losc qui aujourd'hui ekatérinbourg
plusieurs dizaines de personnes sont
mortes
il ya eu des cas similaires dans
d'autres endroits
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas impossible
mais à mon avis il n'y a aucune raison
pour qu'on ne puisse pas simplement
admettre ou croire que ce virus ait pu
apparaître naturellement il ya plus de
femmes ou d'hommes qui meurent les deux
à la fois les femmes et les hommes en
général si des gens se retrouvent ici ce
sont des gens âgés qui finissent en
soins intensifs
oui et aussi des gens qui ont d'autres
maladies obésité diabète maladies du
sang les maladies cardiaques
oui et les maladies du sang parmi les
jeunes qui se retrouvent ici il y a ceux
qui consomment des stupéfiants et par
exemple ceux qui sont dans un état de
conscience minimale qui sont en état
végétatif et ont été aussi infecter des
stupéfiants vous parlez de quoi des gens
qui consomment des stupéfiants et qui
ont été infectés des drogues injectables
oui des drogues injectables cela rend
aussi les choses beaucoup plus
compliquées quand cela va-t-il finir
selon vous jamais toute pandémie dure de
trois à cinq ans généralement c'est
comme ça
et compte tenu de l'état actuel des
choses de l'état actuel de la
vaccination plus vite et les gens seront
vaccinés plus vite c'est chaîne de
contamination seront brisés plus vite
convaincre à ce virus
faites vous vacciner faites vous
vacciner
pour former l'immunité collective il est
clair que le prix est trop élevé pour
former l'immunité collective par le fait
même peur de demander mais parmi vous
qui s'est fait vacciner lever la main à
quelqu'un qui lui il est également
vaccinés je le connais bladimir du yoga
beach
dès février tous ceux qui travaillent
ici sont vaccinés parce que vous êtes un
chef exigeant premier de temps avant
nous nous les russes pour atteindre un
niveau de vaccination d'environ 70 %
avant qu'un nouveau variant encore plus
contagieux encore plus mortelle
n'apparaissent invariants qui
émergeraient par exemple quelque part en
afrique
c'est une question très difficile
et malheureusement la réponse est que
nous sommes déjà en retard
de manière générale toute l'humanité
progressiste fait face aux nouveaux
variants avec un vaccin
oui bien sûr ya l'afrique il y à
l'amérique du sud
il y à certains pays asiatiques ne sont
pas entièrement couvert par la
vaccination
certains pays du moyen orient même à ce
qui concerne le kovacs des pays comme
l'afghanistan et le pakistan sont sur la
liste d'attentes pour la vaccination et
c'est pour 2023
pourquoi la russie alors que c'est son
propre vaccin devrait-elle figurer parmi
les pays où c'est prévu pour 2023
mais c'est la réalité et c'est ce qui se
passe et cela pour des raisons internes
totalement incompréhensible parce que
les gens lisent des choses sur internet
cela me semble en fait un peu ridicule
mais c'est ce qui se passe je crois que
nous sommes déjà en retard sur la
vaccination malheureusement maintenant
il ya des mesures complémentaires en
général la modélisation de l'évolution
d'une épidémie dans une collectivité aux
10% sont vaccinés est effectué selon des
modèles qui ne prennent pas du tout en
compte la vaccination c'est à dire que
nous devons créer un modèle sans
immunité et malheureusement rien de bon
ne découle de ces modèles on peut
améliorer ses modèles en augmentant le
pourcentage de vaccination
mais comme on aura une augmentation non
pas au moment de l'injection mais au
moment de l'apparition de l'immunité il
photo reporter d'un mois et demi à
partir du début d'une campagne active de
vaccination et quand europorte cela on
comprend alors que l'été s'est mal passé
et avec le town nous verrons cancer à
l'automne telle est mon pronostic
malheureusement en l'absence de
médicaments à action directe et il n'y a
pas de tels médicaments contre le
coronavirus ainsi que contre la plupart
des infections virales
il n'existe tout simplement pas la seule
façon d'empêcher la propagation de la
maladie
c'est soit d'aller dans les bois et de
mettre fin à toute communication de
préférence pendant quelques mois mais
vraiment sans tricher soin de respecter
la distanciation très strictement soin
de se faire vacciner
de plus il faut que le plus grand nombre
de personnes possible se fassent
vacciner parce que s'il reste une partie
importante de la population qui n'est
pas vacciné qui est en quelque sorte une
cible pour le virus alors ces personnes
feront l'objet d'un processus constant
civilisationnel d'émergence de nouvelles
formes virales de nouveaux variants que
nous avons mentionné au début et
certains de ces variants non pas en
fonction d'une conception mais
simplement accidentellement peut-être
seront adaptés pour infecter au moins
avec une certaine efficacité
peut-être avec une efficacité légèrement
augmenté les personnes vaccinées et ces
deux processus circulaire commenceront
les non vaccinés et les vaccinés
constitueront une base pour
l'amélioration du virus on n'a pas
besoin de ça mais il n'ya qu'un seul
problème car bien sûr pour se faire
vacciner
on peut parler de l'importance de la
vaccination dans notre pays
mais en fait il est important de
vacciner toute l'humanité
car en effet l'expérience montre que
même si nous étions tous vaccinés ici à
60 ou 70%
cela ne signifierait pas du tout que le
processus soit terminé car vous avez
cité l'exemple de l'afrique est là bas
le niveau de vaccination est pire que
chez nous en ce sens nous avons de quoi
être fier on peut bien imaginer qu'il y
aura une oasis pour le virus ou de
nouvelles formes vont se développer plus
simplement sortir par vagues rouges
[Musique]
et